I think it's that way yeah yes yeah but
we can get in because we've got our
passes okay I've worked in Westminster
for the best part of a decade and so has
my producer Aggie that's who you can
hear there
and still we get lost here sometimes
[Music]
I got my first job as a parliamentary
journalist back in my mid-20s that's
when I first met Aggie also in her first
job
we both know what it's like when you
first start working in Parliament
feeling in awe of the place
intimidated by the building but also the
people in it MPS
to a young person starting out in
politics are like celebrities
it's a privilege but there's another
side to it
the bad behavior the gossip the rumors
it's not called the Westminster Village
for nothing
yeah
like any Village and I should know I
grew up in one everyone knows everyone
else's business
over the years I've heard stories of
sexual harassment and bullying
they mostly stay hidden because powerful
people tend to be protected by the
system and by each other
but now we're going to tell some of
those stories
[Music]
I was told that the guy who hired him
said oh he's a good looking man he
wouldn't do that he has women throwing
themselves at him they're relying on you
not fighting the machine in a way people
treat it as a joke a juicy bit of Gossip
my biggest fear is if I don't speak out
he's going to be around forevermore
spend five years since I worked with her
and if I smell the same perfume that she
wore it still makes me feel nervous you
know basically if it's not feeling right
it's okay
I'm Liz Bates and from Sky News this is
the Open Secret part one the sex pest
there was one story this Summer that
changed the course of British politics
and at the very heart of it was an
accusation of sexual assault you said
that you had drunk far too much that
night Mr Pinscher what exactly happened
in the Carlton Club
about three years ago there was a
complaint made against uh Chris pincher
in the foreign office it was raised with
me
[Music]
prime minister and I want you to know
how sad I am to be giving up the best
job in the world
but then's the brakes
Chris pincher a senior conservative in
charge of party discipline was accused
of groping two men in a private members
Club in central London
but it wasn't what Mr pincher actually
did that brought about the end of Boris
Johnson's Premiership it was the
question of what was already known about
him by who and why did they decide to
promote him anyway
and that's what we're trying to get at
in this podcast was his behavior an Open
Secret and how many other secrets from
all of the political parties are being
kept in the corridors of power
throughout this series Aggie and I are
going to take you Into the Heart of
Westminster behind the grand exterior
through parliament's corridors and into
the offices and bars the bits That You
Don't See
so we've walked just two minutes from
the House of Commons chamber and now we
are in a bar stranger's bar it's the
most famous bar in Parliament on the
Terrace next to the Thames and I think
that's quite essential to this story not
the drinking necessarily but the kind of
Blurred Lines here sometimes between
work and socializing professional and
personal lives can become very
intertwined
yeah I think that's right and it's also
the way that when people work here it's
very different from a normal job it's
not nine to five you're working for a
political course you really care about
so you're working with a lot of people
who have similar views to you're often
expected to be available whenever you're
needed that's evenings weekends even and
you can never really switch off and for
a lot of people their life outside
Westminster takes a back seat yeah and
it can be look a great experience and it
is for loads of people but it does mean
sometimes that kind of normal
professional boundaries sometimes go out
of the window a bit so your colleagues
become your friends and your drinking
buddies and you message them more than
you message your own family and friends
sometimes and often it's quite powerful
Senior People mixing with sometimes
people much younger than them who look
up to them and that can sometimes be
where things go A bit wrong yeah and
there's definitely an attitude among
some definitely not all but some people
in power that they can and do do what
they want and it's been like this for
years and things come out in the
newspapers they've been investigations
reports there have been real efforts to
improve things and I think things have
improved a lot but
based on what we'll hear just not enough
has changed
let's try and find out why
I want to pause here for a minute
because some of the stories you're going
to hear are pretty tough personal
accounts of bullying and sexual
misconduct so if that's not for you
that's fine but if you want to keep
listening we're going to find out what
exactly is going on in Westminster and
try to figure out why despite seemingly
lots of people knowing that this stuff
is going on not enough progress is being
made the first story we're going to hear
actually takes us off the Parliamentary
estate
[Music]
so we are in Central London on our way
to meet a young woman who did work in
Westminster for a while for an MP she's
going to tell us about something that
happened to her is that right yeah
that's right so we've met her a few
times we're always away from Parliament
so right now we're walking down
embankment and we're just going to meet
her in a beer garden in central London
we call her Emily but that isn't her
real name and it's not actually her
voice you'll hear either
she didn't want anyone to know who she
is because she's scared of what the
consequences would be of talking openly
but this is her story in her own words
and the man that she's talking about is
not only an MP but at the time of
recording is also at the top of
government part of the prime minister's
cabinet
I was sexually assaulted by someone
who's now a cabinet minister
and
I was in my early twenties and didn't
really know how to deal with it
I was super drunk he's feeding me more
wine and I'm already quite obviously
Tanked
and I didn't know how like what the time
lapse was
but after a while I was like you know
what would you mind if I just went to
bed
so I went to bed
but obviously he didn't leave me alone
and then
um I woke up the next morning and I
um I realized what had happened
I was clearly quite uncomfortable
and this is corroborated by the fact
that like I was so shocked by it what
had happened I told my housemate as soon
as I got home and my housemate told me
that if it were him he wouldn't tell
anyone what had happened
and so I just went home and went to bed
for the rest of the day
I called a couple of friends a few days
later but didn't pursue anything about
it immediately and was just like holy
[ __ ] this happened
I reported it to an MP I worked for a
couple of years later and I did go to
the police years later as well and had a
very brief chat with them
and decided not to proceed with a formal
complaint because they couldn't give me
any reassurances until I made a formal
statement I was too scared to kick-start
that process and risk it spiraling out
of control
I've seen texts from that night
and from the weeks and months after and
I've spoken to the MP Emily told he told
me he encouraged her to go to the police
it's been really difficult because he
has continued to be promoted and I'm
very clear that he shouldn't be there
but there's nothing that I can do
without putting my career in Jeopardy
and kind of ruining my life and being
re-victimized all over again
I think he has continued to think it's
fine and always makes a point of being
nice to me in front of other people
I mean I was having lunch in Parliament
with a friend of mine and I hadn't seen
him in years
and I genuinely didn't see him
he came over and was like hey how are
you it's so good to see you're doing so
well and I was just like thinking mate
what are you doing
he just has zero shame
another time I went to an event in
Parliament and when I turned up he
turned up and kissed me on the mouth
so instead of going for the cheeks like
a normal person he went straight in and
my friend saw it and was like holy [ __ ]
and he was like sorry accidental and I
was like it wasn't though was it
Emily no longer works in Parliament but
what happened to her still impacts her
life
it's like step one get sexually
assaulted
but your nightmare does not end there
you get bullied and intimidated by this
person who just likes to periodically
remind you that they're still important
for years afterwards
I managed to like get through my life
for several years without giving it a
moment's thought
and
um I think actually the only times that
I've been kind of
um happy in the past couple of weeks
I've been sort of not thinking about it
and just forgetting that it exists
and every time I have to seriously
entertain coming forward
it's like it sort of takes me back to a
weird place
it's actually better today than it was
like sort of five six weeks ago because
I've actually kind of
um almost desensitized myself to it
again
my feelings on it change day to day
I'm sitting there wondering is today the
day that I decide to just like set
everything on fire and go forward
and then I'm like no
my biggest fear is if I don't speak out
um he's going to be around forever more
foreign
[Music]
I mean I don't know about you but I
think the bit that was really so
shocking for me about that was you know
first of all she was so young when it
happened
um she did tell people but nothing was
done and it clearly is still having an
effect on her life and she doesn't want
to speak publicly
because she's worried that if she does
then this will continue to affect her
life and her future it could ruin her
reputation it could ruin her career yeah
and also you know on the flip side he
has just continued to be promoted and
promoted and he is currently in cabinet
and she is sort of worrying about it
every day the consequences of this are
all on her yeah yeah
a government spokesperson said we take
allegations of sexual misconduct
extremely seriously and there are robust
procedures in place to raise concerns
all ministerial appointments also follow
established processes
of course it's worth noting here that
ultimately it's the prime minister at
the moment that's Boris Johnson who
chooses his cabinet and the Civil
Service just can't interfere with that
process
you might be thinking if people knew
about this why was it not dealt with
formally at the time
but as I've said Parliament is not a
normal workplace
and this is where I'm going to break it
down for you
now there has been a scheme set up to
support people who work in Parliament
with things like this but some people
still don't trust it and we'll come back
to that
putting that aside
the options are not great if something
like this happens
and that's because first of all there's
no real formal HR so you can forget that
if you wanted to complain about an MP
for example
the person you might go to First is the
office manager
but they are employed by the MP so their
career is very much in the MP's hands
and they're usually pretty close to them
as well in some cases they're married to
them
so that's not always a great option
you could also go to the party's
headquarters or to the whips they're the
MPS in charge of party discipline
getting their colleagues to do as
they're told basically
but you'd have to bear in mind that
really their priority is to protect the
MPS and the party's reputation
on top of all of this there's a fear
that if you're seen as a troublemaker
then people above you will speak to each
other and basically you'll never get
another job in Westminster
and that's not just a baseless fear I
know people that it has happened to
and that's why accusations like Emily's
don't always get dealt with properly
so when we talk about Westminster we
don't just mean Parliament there's also
Whitehall and we're walking down there
now where there's all the government
departments the civil servants and of
course Downey Street itself and that's
where we're going we just need to get
through these big gates at the front
so now we're standing if you can imagine
opposite at number 10 the big famous
black door now this is usually where all
the journalists and the photographers
gather on those big news days and we've
been here a lot over the past few months
haven't we eggs
yeah we have um I mean journalists spent
hours here covering the final days of
Boris Johnson's Premiership and of
course party gay which actually I think
in many ways is a story about how
professional and personal boundaries can
be blurred in politics so people here
working all hours and sometimes that did
turn into drinking and socializing late
into the night yeah and the reason that
we're here is that we've also spoken to
someone who used to work here Polly is
what we're going to call her that's not
her real name her story concerns someone
who still works here who is a man in a
senior role at number 10 but yeah so
she's different to a lot of people we've
spoken to right because when this thing
happened to her she was actually quite
senior herself yeah and the Power
Balance was actually the other way
around so she was really confident that
she knew how to deal with it she's been
around for years she understands the
processes but in the end that actually
didn't make it any easier to get
something done as she quickly found out
I was working a conservative event at an
evening reception I was with a number of
colleagues in this room it was pretty
like crowded sweaty full of men and
basically I felt someone grabbed my ass
and I turned around and this guy was
just like looking right at me and I was
like you just touched me and he was like
no I didn't and I was like yes you did I
just felt you do it and you're looking
right at me like basically I kicked off
and I told him to leave me the [ __ ]
alone like basically got mouthy
I decided to formally complain partly
because I was like okay this is not the
most egregious or traumatizing but like
how is it that these people just feel
they can behave however they want and
just be protected by an industry that
seems to not particularly care I
complained to cchq I outlined what I
thought should happen next which
basically was he shouldn't be working
for political campaigns if he was
behaving like that he should take
responsibility and this should be logged
in case it happens again so for any
other women that come across this guy
there should be a record
When She Says cchq by the way she's
talking about conservative campaign
headquarters
as a result of Polly's complaint the man
was taken off the election campaign he
was linked to at the time stepped
forward to the present day I heard that
he was going to get a job in Downing
Street I raised it with a number of
people again I wasn't like saying you
should not do this I was saying do you
think this is what you should do are you
grown-ups capable of taking a stand what
kind of message does he send nothing
happened so I then formally complained
to the cabinet office I just felt the
responsibility to do it again partly
because the office he's going to be
working in is full of women and I just
thought he'd do it again after Polly
launched a formal complaint the story
got a bit of media attention I was told
that the guy who hired him said oh he's
a good looking man he wouldn't do that
he has women throwing themselves at him
he said that to a few people and then
basically went mad trying to kill the
story and defend him
I know that all parties have got their
really bad examples of this but the
conservative party have a very special
abilities to try and protect and uphold
power the man who Polly says groped her
is still working in number 10. I think
my mind was really opened about how far
people will go to keep things quiet and
basically just brush everything under
the carpet you've seen how these stories
have been around for a very long time
about people and yet nothing happens and
as long as you've still got somebody at
the top with ultimate power saying I
will not do anything about this it's
just actually a waste of everyone's time
trying to find another way to fire them
because they won't get fired
a government spokesperson told us all
prospective government employees are
subject to necessary checks and vetting
they added we do not comment on
individuals
and a conservative spokesperson told us
we have an established code of conduct
and complaints procedure where people
can report complaints in confidence they
said we take any complaint seriously
so one of the things I found quite
shocking about that story was separately
from what happened was what Polly said
about his boss's reaction when he heard
about the allegations to say he's too
good looking to have done something like
that it's just shows if he did say that
a real level of ignorance on this
subject because anyone can behave like
this yeah it sort of feels like
something you'd hear in the 1960s
doesn't it I think the other thing that
this story really highlights and we
haven't really touched on this yet is
the the real low level stuff that goes
on isn't necessarily clear-cut but it
makes people feel uncomfortable like
people kind of feeling entitled to put
their hands on someone so one example
that comes to mind for me as I was
speaking to a young female journalist
who was trying to get an interview with
an MP in Parliament and during their
conversation he just came really close
to her and while they were talking just
first hand on her hip and she was like I
couldn't I couldn't as I said couldn't
quite put my finger on it but it's made
me feel really uncomfortable yeah and
that's actually
um happened to me as well when I was
much younger as a journalist I was a
conservative party conference I was like
standing in a group of journalists and
an MP came up to the group and stood
close to me and put his hand at the
bottom of my back and just stood there
with it there and I was like oh this is
quite creepy but I just didn't want to
make things awkward so I just didn't say
anything
of course none of this is new people
have been talking about this problem for
years
and that's why in 2017 when the metoo
movement was at its height and stories
were coming out left right and Center
about bad behavior in Parliament
Andrea lets him the then leader of the
house and a senior conservative MP
stood up in the Commons and said this
the house must address the Urgent issue
of alleged mistreatment of Staff by
members of parliament
these allegations make clear that there
is a vital need to provide better
support and protection for the thousands
of Staff members working in Westminster
and in constituency offices across the
country
there can be no place for harassment
abuse or misconduct in politics
your age gender or job title should have
no bearing on the way you are treated in
a modern workplace
Andrew ledson and a group of MPS from
all parties looked into why so many of
these accusations were coming out of
Westminster at the time she agreed to
speak to me about it from her
constituency during the summer recess
it was absolutely clear to me that
people need to have clear set of
responsibilities they need to understand
the extent of their Authority as well as
the extent of their responsibility and
in all of these employment relationships
it just seemed to me that people were
batting around in the dark and then of
course added to which because people
work such long hours in Parliament so
you have restaurants and the restaurants
serve alcohol and there are a few bars
it kind of had that sense of it was a
bit of another University environment
you know you go to the bar after work
and then you get drunk and then you
maybe hang out all evening after the
house has risen and so on so it was very
clear to me that a lot needed to be done
I suppose being perhaps a bit older it
just seemed to me crazy that we hadn't
cracked this
so at this point in 2017 ipsa
the independent parliamentary standards
Authority had existed for quite a few
years right since the expense of Scandal
so why wasn't that body ensuring proper
practices were being observed what ipsa
was designed to do was to express one
problem only and that was the issue of
MP's expenses whereas for my money what
it should have done was to
professionalize the whole employment
relationship and the biggest missing
piece which I tried very hard to get
included then is the tips that don't
provide any kind of HR and ipsa would
not do that even when the whole Scandal
hit Westminster and I was saying to them
you know you really need to step up here
no no no they weren't interested so what
we ended up with was the independent
complaints and grievance scheme which we
wanted to develop for harassment sexual
harassment and bullying so look this is
something that you've always been really
personally can committed to why is that
you know we are the role models for the
country you know if we allow bullying
and harassment and sexual harassment to
go on unchecked then we're setting a
terrible role model for the rest of
society so I want us to kind of
demonstrate the best and at the moment
we're not quite there
[Music]
CGS was launched in 2018 and between
then and June 2021 nearly a thousand
people have contacted its helpline
one of the most high profile cases it
has dealt with is James
again not his real name can you hear me
okay is this headset okay yeah yeah I
can hear you
he was subjected to unwanted sexual
advances from an MP Patrick Grady who
was at the time with the Scottish
national party
as a result of the accusations he's now
sitting as an independent
the incident happened back in 2016 when
James was still a teenager and Patrick
Grady was in his late 30s
five years later James reported it to
the icgs and a year after that they
upheld his complaint
following that he went to the
Metropolitan Police but earlier this
year they chose to take no further
action
so in the end the punishment for Patrick
Grady was a two-day suspension from
Parliament
for James the impact lasted a little
longer
he says that after he made the complaint
he felt he had to leave his job because
it became a non-roll with no work to do
and no route back to normality
so then body it for a while but it took
a long time to process and have the
courage to to come out with it you know
things I was worried about did happen so
not as a result of all of this and I've
lost my job but uh the MPS are still in
their job so let's go back to 2016 when
this all started can you tell me exactly
what happened yeah um so the issue the
incident with myself and Patrick greedy
um happened when I was 18 or 19 years
old I think I might have just turned 19
and Patrick came over towards me and sat
on uh purchased himself in the arm of
the coach on my left hand side while he
did that the right hand side of the
couch was a free sheep so he chose to
perch himself on the arm instead of sit
next to me
um and after that he started to put his
fingers down the back of my collar in
the back of my neck and at the time I
was wearing a certain tie and so to get
your fingers down the back of my neck
wouldn't have been an easy thing to do
give it out of tie on my thought
button-up shirt it was quite tight so
you had to be quite forceful to do that
he was also played with my hair and
making comments like I wish I had here
while doing it uh which just sort of
made the whole thing even more creepy to
be honest and harder to handle
um you know I hadn't really received
much attention like this from a man
before so at the time at 19 years old
and keep in mind this is my dream job um
I always worked the working Westminster
and I get there and it's the first year
of my job
um and this MP who's you know almost
twice my age is not only making a move
on but he's touching me without my
consent and making comments about my
hair and wishing that he had it too so
it was it was just a very very
such situation to be part of I look back
at now I'm 25 and I can see how wrong it
is and you know if I could go back I
wish I would do things differently and
say something at the time but at 19
years old the junior member of Staff
there's an MP doing something someone
that has a lot of
influence over my career it wasn't
really something I wanted to divide me
straight off the bat uh you know this is
the guy that got harassed on Patrick
Grady don't don't speak to him stay away
from him that can I don't want that to
happen what happened to James was
witnessed by someone else in the party
and it was eventually reported to the
smp's Westminster leader Ian Blackford
he made Patrick Grady apologize but
allowed him to stay in his role as
James's boss
years later when Patrick Grady was
suspended from Parliament over the
incident the SMP leader and his MPS
talked about it in a private meeting
which was recorded and leaked to the
Daily Mail
the sounds not great on that but that's
Ian Blackford saying that everyone needs
to Rally around not James the victim but
the perpetrator Patrick Grady
the story caused up raw a few weeks
later I bumped into Ian Blackford
outside my office in Westminster take
her responsibility and have you
apologized to the victim because you
said you should rally around Patrick
Grady I've offered to meet the victim
and make it sure that out of all of this
and put us this case or any other that
the interests of the victim must come
from the victim says
you have it all or apologize to him um
yes I have that I put a statement over
it just exactly that and I would rate it
again that I apologize for everything
that the victim has gone through nobody
should feel unsafe in Parliament whether
it's in this case or any other case
of this made everything a lot worse and
his failure to
um take responsibility for that
uh you know it's not just shocking it's
disappointing but it puts every staff
member for the s p at risk working for
him but ultimately it's me that's paying
the price for this the same piece
they're walking around as an MP claiming
to be exonerated uh and I'm out of a job
so yeah it's just it's a one-way Street
and it's there to it's designed to
protect the members of parliament so why
do you think Westminster is like this
why is there this culture where MPS feel
like they can behave like this and just
get away with it when they went to
Westminster they're leaving their family
they're leaving their friends and their
life there and they're going down to the
Big Smoke London and in the bars of
Western so there's no CCTV there's
sometimes a journalist or two but you
know it's really it's behind closed
doors what happens there
um and even if something bad happens to
you want to complain it might not get
found out because there is no CCTV a lot
of Witnesses are colleagues they don't
affect their
um careers too so it's like a private
members Club in that way it really
really is so I also remember you telling
me about a comment that was made to you
after another incident this time I think
it was with a female MP uh another
Member of Parliament who I won't name
um approached me in the strangers bar
which is actually where the alleged
harassment had happened
um and had said to me that uh you know I
understand you've got someone wanted
attention from an MP the other night
um and I said yes uh and he said you
know you should have gone home with her
because she had a tight Fanny an MP said
that that was a member of the parliament
for the Scottish national party that
said that to me wow okay
um and I think you said some other
people said some pretty dismissive
things to you about the um Patrick Grady
incident as well right someone in your
office
um he's turned around on his computer to
your strong round
um I was talking to him and said to me
you know it's not like you pinch you
against the wall and raped you is it
which just goes to show really the
attitude in Westminster towards this
sort of behavior like it is tolerated to
an extent there is a line of Tolerance
you're allowed to maybe Pat someone on
the bomb you're maybe allowed to put
your finger down someone's back of
someone's neck maybe you can kiss them
without consent but as long as you don't
rape them and to me that is is abhorrent
and horrific but it really does show the
culture inside Westminster and how
people view this kind of thing you know
basically if it's not full and rape it's
okay
we reached out to the SMP about what
James told us and one of their
spokespeople said the SMP takes all
complaints seriously and the
Parliamentary group fully accepted and
implemented the recommendations of the
icgs
the individual concerned they mean James
here was offered support throughout the
process and we have also initiated a
review of Staff support to consider any
improvements that could be made
a few people have talked about a whisper
Network
a sort of informal safeguarding system
where people who've been around for a
while warn others about who to stay away
from but it's not just staff and civil
servants everyone talks about this
including MPS
first floor
um can I see what the writing is
Charlotte Nichols is a labor MP elected
in 2019 she's also a young woman new to
Parliament whose status still hasn't
protected her from predatory behavior
she shares her office right oh yeah this
is her door okay
in order to
survive in Westminster you do have to
rely on that whisper Network
um ultimately
it's never going to be 100 effective you
know some of the most dangerous people
are probably the last people that you'd
ever suspect
you know I have been repeatedly
propositioned by an MP who is old enough
to be my grandfather
um sometimes in front of other
colleagues who have either laughed off
or said nothing when he's done it
I know from speaking to other people
that um you know this is not uncommon
behavior for him
um and in some respects
you know perhaps I feel
lucky compared to some of the other
people who've had worse from him it sort
of gets laughed off as you know that's
just who he is he's very old school
um you know sort of back in the day that
was acceptable but you know yeah it's
2022
um and you know I'm not convinced that
colleagues 10 20 years ago would have
found the sorts of things that he says
any more flattering than I do frankly
it's something that he clearly feels
emboldened to do that he feels entitled
to do and I think the lack of action or
consequence and the fact that his name
is spoken about quite openly that
everyone knows what he's like
um and that you know he's not the only
one
there's been so many attempts to sort
this out over the years and yet it still
feels like it's just ingrained in the
culture here do you know why that is
so I think the people who are kind of
actively perpetrating it are very much
in the minority but a lot of them are
also quite Brazen about it
I think you have a
another larger cohort
who are sort of bystanders who often
witness these things but maybe don't say
anything
and then I think you have
a bigger group of people who when these
sorts of things are said they're much
more interested in the damage that it
does to their party or to Parliament as
institution than they are about
resolving the issue
we contacted the House of Commons to ask
what they made of this and a
spokesperson said to us that bullying
harassment and sexual harassment have
absolutely no place in Parliament
parliament's independent complaints and
grieving scheme was set up to enable
anybody in the Parliamentary Community
to report mistreatment in confidence
they told us they want to make sure
everyone working in Parliament feels
able to report such instances and they
said they know that at present there are
still barriers to this happening and
that there is still work to be done to
ensure that everyone is treated with the
respect and dignity they deserve
okay so we're back where we started
actually on the Terrace in the bar we've
heard all these stories here about
sexual misconduct and I think the really
shocking thing for me is that some of
these people are still in top jobs and
it does seem at this point like they are
probably not going to face up to these
allegations the other thing is they're
not isolated incidents
this is still a bit of a culture and
these are just some of the stories that
we've heard but there were a lot more I
do think we need to stay here though and
everyone we spoke to wanted to stress
this is not all MPS this is not everyone
in positions of power and politics
they're not All Creeps far from it and
most of them are actually in it for
really good reasons and if the right
reasons want to help people but when
people do bad things the processes
aren't necessarily in place to protect
people and this place has a long way to
go before it becomes a modern working
environment 100 and the other thing is
we've gone through all of these stories
about kind of predatory behavior but the
other thing of course is that whilst we
were speaking to people about this lots
of people came to us to talk about
something else entirely and that was
bullying and I think that is something
that we really need to look into
I think she's built some makeup or
something she came in with cleaning
stuff I must like there are stains all
over the carpet you should clean those
up so I was literally on my hands and
knees on the floor next time on the Open
Secret the bully it's been five years
since I worked for her and if I smell
the same perfume that she wore it still
makes me feel nervous we're still
working on this episode and we'll get it
to you as soon as we can
in the meantime if you want to get in
touch about anything you've heard so far
I'm on Twitter and you can contact me
directly my DMs are open
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]